le païen georges asbeck mots qui sont
sur place à kiev qu'elle je vous le
disais à pilonner 1 ce matin en corse et
je ne sais pas si vous m'entendez faites
moi signe peut-être
bonjour cyril ravi de vous entendre
accompagné georges-besse je le disais
expliquez-nous peut-être qui est en
train de se passer au moment où l'on se
parle les russes faisaient état de
corridors humanitaires
ce matin encore d'un accord avec les
autorités ukrainiennes que se passe-t-il
concrètement à kiev 1 c'est là vous vous
trouvez sont utiles
je ne sommes alors nous sommes pas à
kiev nous venons de contourner pendant
une heure et demie
la zone nord-ouest pour arriver dans les
environs de boudhha et dire pin et de ce
tome elle qui sont justement l'endroit
de ces corridors humanitaires
nous venons de vous nous arrêtent et
nous mettre en direct avec vous je ne
sais pas si vous pouvez voir cette
épaisse fumée noire qui s'élève dans le
ciel juste derrière moi je pense que
georges va zoomer dessus il vient
d'avoir à l'instant alors que nous nous
attendons sur cette même route un
corridor humanitaire d'un moment à
l'autre d'ailleurs la police nous a
empêchés d'aller plus loin alors qu'on
attend un convoi humanitaire de réfugiés
des villes dire pin de boudhha et de ce
tome elle nous voulons entendre des
bombardements
plusieurs salves ça a duré environ
quatre minutes extrêmement près d'ici il
y a une maison qui a été touché les
forces sur place nous empêche d'aller
plus loin donc voilà même scénario qui
lie à 24 heures ddd trêve des
cessez-le-feu sont annoncés et sur le
terrain voilà c'est ces fumées des
bombardements et au milieu de cela et
bien ce convoi humanitaire que l'on
attend d'un moment à l'autre donc ça
révèle encore d'abord l'extrême
fragilité de ces corridors humanitaires
peut être le double langage où le
cynisme des autorités militaires russes
qui font sortir les civils et qu'ils
continuent les tirs de mortier voyez ce
sont des forces d'autodéfense qui
sortent la très grande vitesse et donc
ce double langage ceci dit mme cette
stratégie d'épuisement de la population
puisque l'amour où je vous parle il y as
certainement de voitures qui commencent
à arriver ce sont certainement
des évacués décès de ces zones au
nord-ouest de kiev où il ya d'intenses
combats une énorme pression depuis trois
jours ils vont certainement être en
train d'arriver mais sous le feu de tirs
d'artillerie ou de bombardements qui
viennent de s'arrêter mais là encore une
fois c'est l'essai de fumée continue de
se dégager il y a une odeur saturé de
poudre dans cette région dans cette zone
donc on est vraiment dans une zone à la
fois des évacuations mais où le cessez
le feu est extrêmement précaire et en
tout cas n'a pas l'air d'être
extrêmement suivie ici sur le terrain
dans la région dit mme pin et je ne sais
pas si vous êtes en mesure de rester
encore avec nous sur et vous me dites on
est en train de vivre si vous nous
rejoignez en direct qui se passe donc
dans cette dans cette région avec cette
équipe
d'envoyé d'envoyés spéciaux cyril on
s'attelle à donner la priorité en
priorité la parole aux ukrainiens
qu'est-ce qui vous racontent ces
ukrainiens vous avez pu rencontrer ces
dernières heures envoyés derrière vous
ces véhicules en train de en train de
fuir si je ne me trompe pas
oui effectivement parce que encore une
fois ici nous venons d'arriver et nous
avons été stoppés vous avez voyez un
checkpoint la base d'un barrage et on
est dans une zone dite d'évacuation
c'est à dire que c'est un des corridors
humanitaires
je rappelle que la zone dire pin est
relié par une grande autoroute qui mène
au centre-ville et ce pont et il ya un
pont qui a été détruit d'abord pour
empêcher la progression des forces
russes bien évidemment mais ça empêche
aussi considérablement les dizaines de
milliers de résidents de ces de ces
zones périphériques de la capitale
ukrainienne de sortir donc ces corridors
humanitaires qui avait été on le pensait
négocié depuis ce matin 8 heures pour
une une durée de 8 heures jusqu'à ce
soir et bien permettez l'acheminement de
ces convois que l'on attend d'un instant
à l'autre mais sans doute ont-ils été se
sont-ils arrêté en amont là où je me
trouve à cause des tirs qu'on l'on colle
on vient d'essuyer les tirs d'artillerie
donc une situation précaire mais encore
une fois comme depuis ce matin il y a eu
une nuit assez tendue avec énormément de
d'alert aux bombardements aériens à kiev
et d'en arriver aux alentours des
bombardements jusqu'au moment du
cessez-le-feu juste après
le levée du couvre feu vers 7 heures du
matin une situation extrêmement précaire
et personne ne croit vraiment à ces
notions de corridors humanitaires à ces
notions de cessez le feu puisque on l'a
bien vu depuis le début de l'offensive
il ya je le rappelle maintenant deux
semaines que ça soit à kharkhiv à
marioupol wac hersov et bien l'armée
russe n'a jamais nécessairement
respecter ces cessez le feu il a plutôt
utilisé cessez le feu pour laisser à
sortir les civils et multiplié les tirs
d'artillerie les bombardements c'est ce
que en tout cas on est en train de
vérifier voilà c'est un quartier de
boudhha nous sommes dans la banlieue de
kef dans le nord-ouest un quartier de
bout de chaque était en feu justement
cyril les forces russes le kremlin se
défend de viser des cibles civiles alors
c'est vrai que les images de deux morts
sont extrêmement rares il est
extrêmement difficile de couvrir au plus
près cette guerre ce conflit que
pouvez-vous vous témoigner vous qui vous
en ai régulièrement plus près des zones
de tirs
au but écoutez c'est qu'on n'est pas du
tout dans une on est sincèrement pas du
tout dans une logique de une logique de
de calme je dirais il n'y a pas de
cessez-le-feu depuis trois jours on
entend parler ici tout le monde se lève
dans cette région de kiev mais je
pourrais et ornent également aux autres
zones encerclées d'ukraine donc
marioupol
kharkiv personnes on parle de corridors
humanitaires mais au même moment
parallèlement il y a toujours des
bombardements des tirs et ce rouleau
compresseur de l'armée russe qui
continue donc ici évidemment ce matin
très sincèrement ce n'est même plus du
scepticisme assez de la colère par
rapport à cette stratégie dont on sait
de deux heures de moscou par dont on
sait qu'elle a été largement utilisé sur
d'autres terrains de conflit on pense à
la syrie on pense à la tchétchénie alors
ce n'est pas le même scénario kiev on le
sait ne sera pas rasé ça sera difficile
pour le pour vladimir poutine est bien
de vendre ça a son opinion c'est kiev
est une ville hautement symbolique il ne
sera pas rasé certainement pas au moins
on l'espère c'est pour ça qu'on ne
redoute pas de gros bombardements à
l'intérieur de kiev
compte par contre et ça c'est ce qu'on
vit maintenant en direct et bien
l'encerclement le siège de kiev est en
train de se préparer résolument et c'est
ce qu'on voit ici et la stratégie
militaire de de moscou et de faire
sortir les civils pour certainement se
dédouaner pour dire ce qu'ils ne fuient
pas sont les combattants où sont nos
opposants et bien nous nous battrons
contre eux merci beaucoup inspiré de
paille argent js bach